euh en combien de temps déjà parce que
j'ai besoin de savoir ce que je prépare
l'été là 3h
vraiment
perdre du poids ça dépend ça
dépendent 45 non arrêtez si vous avez 5
kg à perdre et ben c'est c'est à moi un
mois à moi bonne journée 13 à perdre
vous avez
un peu plus hein
alors aujourd'hui vous proposez une
nouvelle méthode mon but est d'intégrer
à son alimentation trois fight food
pauvre et non transformé c'est quoi des
fight food c'est des aliments de combat
si vous voulez le vous êtes posé la
question de savoir pourquoi j'ai eu du
succès je me pose dans mon au début moi
dans mon régime il y avait le son
d'avoine et le son d'avoine vous pouvez
pas imaginer non il y a le mur du son
mais c'est pas le cas d'accord je crois
que c'était le bruit
elle a les yeux évolué
le son d'avoine ça a beaucoup fait ça a
beaucoup aidé le régime parce que je
pensais quelque chose à consommer c'est
des galettes vous avez des crêpes on
faisait du pain voilà donc ça met et là
si vous voulez ça c'était mon premier
faillite mon deuxième ça a été le konjac
konjac le konjac c'est des pâtes et du
riz qui est fait avec une poudre de
konjac qui fait 9 calories ou 100 g 9
calories
dans l'estomac
avant même que vous le consommiez c'est
des pâtes c'est des pâtes et du riz si
on était au départ des produits un peu
difficiles qui étaient suivis que par
les les grandes adeptes de la perte de
poids et puis qui progressivement est
passé en deuxième génération en
troisième génération aujourd'hui on a
des plats des plats cuisinés qui sont
délicieux de la des paella on a des
risotto on a des bolognaises voilà donc
pour moi si vous voulez personnellement
je vous donne mon avis et c'est c'est un
aliment prodigieux
le konjac par exemple
[Rires]
ça se trouve en grande surface
alors écoutez vous prenez un plat de
konjac par jour vous faites rien d'autre
notre régime pas de truc vous vivez
comme d'habitude vous perdez 1 kg de
plus par mois 1 kg
vous connaissez même pas il y a 2
millions en plus du reste tu manges que
tu veux donc si mais en plus
vous continuez mais vous ajoutez vous
ajoutez un plat de Jacques par jour
etc
alors si vous faites en même temps le
régime je prends
plus on fait le régime je fais du Tarik
trois aliments qui est magique c'est
okara c'est ce qui reste
au carrément l'amour donc quand vous
pressez je l'ai appelé comme ça sur le
paquet il y a marqué ou carrément c'est
qui parce que je l'aime alors quand vous
pressez des graines quand vous pressez
des graines
de soja
ça fait du lait de soja cool du lait de
soja et dans le pressoir ce qui reste le
régime du c'est le l'okara c'est le cas
parce que c'est bourré de protéines et
c'est bourré d'une fibre dans une
qualité extraordinaire et vous en prenez
une cuillère à soupe par jour donc en
poudre vous mettez
les courses
il faut le presser
en fait c'est tout vous ouvrez la bouche
non c'est vrai ça sert à quoi exactement
ça sert à quoi ça sert à compenser vous
sentiez d'un repas trop sucré trop gras
c'est le mauvais repas je sors de chez
ma mère
alors donc là je sors je suis ballonné
dans ma communauté quand vous dites à
votre mère je suis au régime et qu'elle
a fait un plat elle vous dit alors tu
m'aimes pas c'est ça alors tu m'aimes
pas alors vous mangez parce que vous
aimez votre mère voilà et c'est un drame
c'est le problème 40 kg on est maman
et donc comment faire avec ces trois
aliments pour les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent alors on fait l'origine
alors c'est à base de ces trois aliments
moi j'aime bien savoir matin midi et
soir moi j'aime bien avoir des routes
alors attendez exactement attendez
feuille de route Cyril c'est un mariage
entre mon régime le régime traditionnel
que j'ai depuis le début et c'est trois
faillite c'est à dire que vous commencez
par une période de temps si vous avez un
admettons vous avez 10 kilos à perdre 4
jours d'attaque dans lequel vous avez
droit 4 jours de conduire de quatre
jours de d'attaque de phase d'attaque
dans lequel vous avez toutes les viandes
maigres tous les poissons tous les gras
les maigres les boîtes les conserves le
saumon fumé vous avez les fruits de mer
tous vous avez la tout sauf les becs
plates canards et doit vous en fait quoi
sont gras je sais pas pourquoi
vous avez
vous avez tous les détails
vous avez tous les étages vous avez
toutes les protéines végétales comme le
tofu comme le le seitan le tempé vous
connaissez pas vous êtes pas végétarien
mais il y a des gens qui sont voilà donc
vous avez de ça autant que vous voulez
vous mangez le jour la nuit les heures
c'est libre pour éviter les frites les
frites les frites rien d'autre
les frites c'est comme si vous
souhaitiez du balcon
alors je sais pas si vous avez vu des
frites c'est catastrophique
il y a pire que les frites
alors les chips
c'est une catastrophe c'est une personne
et en plus ça a été d'un cuit dans une
huile Leicester même les chiffres
artisanales même les chipsters
puis vous me cherchez là
je peux pas vous dire aussi
catastrophique oui je vous aime bien
écouter j'ai envie que vous continuez
les pâtes les pâtes les pâtes alors les
pâtes ça dépend les pâtes alors si vous
aimez pas les souffrances et j'ai un
deuxième régime qui s'appelle le régime
tendre le régime c'est un régime qui se
passe ça s'appelle l'escalier
nutritionnel pourquoi escalier parce que
lundi c'est protéines
alors le lundi protéine pure mardi
protéine légumes mercredi protéine
fruits durs dans le milieu du sexe fruit
ton savon chaque jour il y a un Père
Noël qui arrive en vous donnant une
nouvelle famille d'aliments la vie c'est
pas ravioli d'habitude
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
total une bande de billets il en peut
plus vite donc c'est quoi là donc
docteur donc chaque jour il y a une
famille nouvelle et en fin de semaine la
maison c'est-à-dire légumes fruits fin
grillé fromage le samedi des féculents
des pâtes des trucs comme ça et le
dimanche un repas de gala un repas de
gala
vous vous avez droit à tout ce que vous
voulez mais une dose le dimanche une
entrée libre
[Rires]
si vous cherchez la bagarre
c'est catastrophique non non si vous
avez fait la semaine comme je vous l'ai
dit le repas de gala
de toute manière vous prenez une portion
parce que votre estomac c'est un petit
rétrécit
vous savez les gens qui font du régime
ils ont quand même envie de maigrir bien
sûr vous bon vous me blaguez mais bon
ils ont envie de m'aider vous pouvez pas
imaginer la souffrance des gens qui
souffrent d'un disque 15 20 kg surtout
les femmes parce que parce que c'est
leur pouvoir de séduction qui est un peu
gêné par cette petite voix les yeux les
yeux de quelqu'un qui a 20 kilos de trop
ils sont plus fermés on voit plus le
blanc
[Applaudissements]
faut revenir sur le régime les 21h10 on
dirait que c'est important pour être
spectateurs donc remettez les trois
aliments s'il vous plaît c'est pas la
peine de mettre ça on s'en fout mettez
les trois aliments
donc ça on essaie de manger ça tous les
jours
le matin vous faites votre galette ou
bien vous faites du pain etc le konjac
avec du pain non vous faites du pain
avec ça
[Rires]
dans son lit
oui donc là donc là donc là je fais le
pain enfin oui voilà
pudding avec un peu de lait etc c'est
une boulangerie
mais quand on sait rien faire comme moi
et qu'on a à la maison
ça vous faites vous mettez une cuillère
et demi de ça une cuillère et demi de
fromage blanc un œuf et vous faites un
aller-retour sur la poêle et ça vous
prend 4 minutes
mariez-vous ça va coûter beaucoup plus
cher cette merde
[Applaudissements]
c'était beaucoup plus cher faisons
plutôt ça
comment ça commence à venir le konjac ça
c'est le midi
tiens regarde je vous donne ma parole
que j'en prends moi à la maison et j'ai
pas besoin de maigrir
alors
écoutez-moi je voudrais vous dire
quelque chose je sais pas si vous avez
vu sur la couverture du livre que j'ai
écrit ce livre avec ma fille Pierre
Dukan et Maya Dukan Maya Dukan et pour
moi si vous voulez c'est pour moi j'ai
une naturopathe donc elle elle voit les
choses différemment de voix moi je suis
un allopathe je suis un dur de Dieu elle
elle ouvre elle elle est large elle
mélange pratiquement beaucoup de choses
et pour moi si vous voulez la relève est
présente bien sûr pour moi c'est c'est
vous pouvez pas imaginer ce que c'est
que pour un père d'avoir une fille qui
qui m'a suivi dans mon sillage à
montmaya
alors je vais vous dire une chose vous
savez pourquoi sur Maya un jour je suis
dans mon cabinet une femme s'assie en
face de moi je l'avais jamais vu elle
avait un nom un petit peu germanique et
elle me dit je lui dis prénom elle me
dit Maya
tout de suite ça me touche et je lui dis
et ben ma fille s'appelle Maya alors
elle me dit et pourquoi elle s'appelle
Maya et j'ai dit parce que j'ai une
passion pour Picasso et sa fille
s'appelait Maya non moi j'ai une passion
pour Maya l'abeille
regardez tous les épisodes oui non oui
mais moi c'était avant je lui dis ça et
vous savez ce qu'elle me répond elle me
dit c'est moi non
j'ai eu des frissons
[Rires]